[Music]
little boy who lost the bed now wrecking
up the kills I got to pay the bills the
bills for what you get is a way to hit
reset give you War just up the H got
Ling all those days are death there's
theiling ceiling
let's get it so keeping yourself you're
keeping yourself a f you're keeping
yourself you're yourself
the you got get what you
get best sh go out get got to go reach
out
get out get you get out reach out for we
TR to get you better go we to
get to get get in get out get on do
it game over but they give him all the
street co little KY in the gutter with
the bloody nose undercover but he
doesn't even be the headlines the
hand
Ang from every with power
[Applause]
[Music]
and